all right last night uh people probably
wish they were watching mr mercedes
instead of watching the football game
between the eagles and the cowboys it
had a weird feel
it had like it had like a fourth game of
the pre-season feel
didn't it like they're trying out
different things and the crowds really
care
no nobody really cares who's winning or
losing wasn't there just a weird vibe
around that game
yes i mean there was one team that i
don't think had any belief they could
win the football game and another team
that was going
no wait here you can win here here's the
ball
yeah i promise you we'll let you try to
win we'll let you win
come on i mean it was unbelievable you
know i mean it just
it was like you know first off i guess i
have to talk about
carson wentz because that's just the
first thing that comes to my mind i mean
because i like him
you know i defend him and there's not a
lot of help around him
and that's certainly a part of the
struggle but damn
i mean some of those turnovers last
night come on carson wins
i mean you just can't i don't care if
there's no talent you just gotta
sometimes take the sack
throw the ball away i mean the two strip
sack fumbles
he was so oblivious that there was
somebody around him and about to hit him
that that just can't happen not against
a team like dallas where
you're you're supp you're not even good
but you're superior to them
and you let them hang around and really
i mean dallas just
they did their best to screw it up they
were given a gift
and they were like wait we don't know
how to tear paper and open up a gift
how do you take the bow off i mean they
truly were it was unbelievable
um i don't know what to say the nfc is
so
crappy i've never seen it like this ever
the eagles have
some inklings of being good but damn uh
that just was not yeah it was not a good
game holy cow
let's hear from eagles quarterback
carson wentz talking about his
not so great performance last night in a
14-point victory
too many turnovers i got to be better um
there's mistakes out there some of it
maybe not on the same page some of it i
got it you know the first fumble i gotta
throw the ball away
um you know that stuff i can keep
cleaning up and you know
obviously it's it's stuff that uh
individually i can get better at
and um some of these shots down the
field i mean i'm gonna keep giving these
guys
chances and and you know i can be better
and put the ball in the right spot but
i'm not gonna change my aggressive
mentality um but we're gonna start
connecting on some of those big plays
and
um obviously it hurt us a little bit
today but the defense played great and
we gotta win
look i am not one to excessively
criticize the
clothing choices of quarterbacks after
games but let me just say can we pull up
a still shot of that
it looks like he was a participant in
some sort of a game show where you have
to run into a closet and get dressed as
fast as you can
with just whatever clothes are nearby
and that's the end result
doesn't it yes i don't i know am i wrong
no you're not i don't know this i don't
know what what look he's going for hey
chris
chris yes apparently you you can hide
money oh
well yeah seriously okay when he needs
to stop
he needs to start hiding the ball a
little bit and stop giving it to the
other team
you know like listen i love his
aggressiveness and yeah they're gonna
need them to be aggressive
but you've talked about it for a long
time and it's just to the point now
where yeah i like them and i see the top
end of them but like
some of the negatives it's annoying and
it just keeps reoccurring to where
you're annoyed with it now
you're just like what how do you throw
that interception against the giants on
thursday night a few weeks ago in the
end zone
and then you know this last night yeah
okay be aggressive i understand it but
he plays too aggressive to a fault to
where it's like he has no
scope of how the game is playing out or
what's being done that way
and that's cost them this year you know
in a lot of moments so
again he has to fix that the eagles are
getting healthy and man if they could
get just another receiver healthy
and things like that they they might
have a say in this thing but
uh they're just all over the place
here's a trivia question for you and i
don't know that this officially counts
as the
sunday surprise draft trivia question it
does okay a little preview
last night carson wentz threw his 10th
career interception
on a ball into the end zone that's tied
for the second most since he entered the
league in 2016.
who has more interceptions
on balls thrown in the end zone since
2016. well i mean
the the answer you i think of jameis
winston i mean
is that right that's a safe answer for
anyone
yeah when it comes to the category of
interceptions but no it's philip rivers
oh bill pervis has 11. yeah and ben
roethlisberger has 10.
and roseburger just picked up two
against the titans last week
remember those you're right you're right
yeah uh so
uh yeah it has to be listen the eagles
they're not there's no room for error
and if they want to get healthy and
maybe win a playoff game or have a say
you know he can't continue to play that
way and put his team in those positions
i mean it's again it's just doing too
much at times so where he's got to reign
it in
and play the position a little more true
to form and like we always talk about
just have a feel for
the other team you're playing and where
the game is at
that's how we lost week one to
washington you know they get they
couldn't do anything
and he made stupid mistakes there got
them start jump started and that's why
they won that game
ben denucci was 21 for 40 180 yards no
touchdowns no picks two lost fumbles
he'll be back on the bench assuming that
andy dalton is cleared for the steelers
coming to town
this weekend and it's always a special
game when the steelers and the cowboys
play and it will still be a special game
but the cowboys are just
so bad right now and it felt like they
had a chance to win they led for a while
i thought they were going to cover and
and let me tell you there's going to be
a lot of blow back today
yeah about what on that play that
allowed the eagles to cover see this is
one of the realities of
officiating errors in an age of
legalized sports betting
even though it didn't affect the outcome
of the game that
seven points scored in lightning strike
fashion when there was a fumble
and vinnie curry of the eagles was on
the ground with the ball
and he was clearly contacted by a
cowboys player
but did he clearly have possession you
know that's where that's where it was
dicey this is
i i thought he i thought when you apply
common sense to what you see
yes he did and this is where the nfl
can be a little hyper technical in its
requirement of clear and obvious
evidence i remember when dean blandino
was the head of officiating there was a
play i think it was a bear seahawks game
where there was a punt that that
came down and the question was did it
touch the leg
of the player on the return team
therefore making it a live ball
and even though you couldn't actually
see the ball
touch the leg you saw enough
of a change of direction that it touched
something blandino's explanation was we
must have
visual evidence at the time the standard
was indisputable visual evidence same
idea just different words right
we must see we must see it with our eyes
so if you don't see the ball hit the guy
if you if the angle is
the ball goes behind the leg and then
jumps in a different direction that's
not enough well that doesn't make any
sense well
i think that same mindset was applied
last night
because you couldn't actually see yeah
the ball in the possession even though
you know
from watching football for years that
vinnie curry had that ball well yeah but
this is
that's why i think they made that call i
i get that i guess this is where i
i i don't have a problem with the ball
still and being called loose
because within that scrum of when yeah
he had a pin down his right thigh
and then it kind of came up into his
belly but i didn't really think he had
it like locked away and secure
if that ball stayed in there in the
scrum and dallas came out with it
they would have gone dallas ball they
wouldn't have been like oh no no
nope nope he had the ball he recovered
it that scrum didn't happen
so that's to me where you have to let
that go because they let those type of
things go
all the time and don't give the team it
looks like he had early possession in
the scrum and then
20 guys jump in there and the other team
had it so
if you're going to let it play out that
way then you need to
yeah i mean i guess what i'm saying is
you know
yeah you know what i'm saying you got it
yeah and the end result is this
they were not going to overturn whatever
the ruling field was there wasn't enough
evidence either way to
show that a decision of possession or no
possession was incorrect
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports